There's no way to introduce this next story
other than simply to tell you what happened,
which is that Donald Trump congratulated Poland
on the 80th anniversary of World War II.
Of course, the Holocaust sort of started with
Germany's invasion of Poland.
It's not exactly something to be congratulating
them about.
Other leaders sent messages of somber remembrance
and reflection, some even warning about sliding
back towards the type of authoritarianism
that we saw early in the third Nazi Reich.
But Trump congratulates Poland for having
been invaded by Germany 80 years ago.
Take a look at this.
Yeah, I do have a great message.
Football.
And then we have Mike Pence.
Our vice president is just about landing right
now and he is representing me.
I look forward to being there soon, but I
just want to congratulate Poland.
Just a great country with great people.
We also have many Polish people in our country.
It could be 8 million.
Uh, we love our Polish friends as I will be
there soon.
There is no question.
I mean, the analysis here is very simple.
Trump has no idea what Poland's role was in
World War II.
He just had no idea what the historical context
was.
So he said, I congratulate them.
I mean just, he just doesn't know anything.
That's it.
Trump was going to go to Poland for the World
War Two remembrance.
He canceled the trip because of Hurricane
Dorian.
So he was asked instead for a message on this
anniversary of a very, very dark day for Poland
back in 1939 and his message was, congratulations.
What was possibly the darkest day in Polish
history?
And Donald Trump congratulates them.
This is indistinguishable from satire.
If I said to someone, what's the worst possible
thing you could say to Poland on the 80th
anniversary of being raped and pillaged by
the Nazis?
Congratulations would be pretty high on the
list.
He does not know what happened in World War
II.
Period.
Poland lost a fifth of its population during
World War II.
A much bigger percentage of the Jewish population
was lost in Poland during World War II.
Congratulations guys.
A message of this is not very different than
congratulating Israel on Holocaust Remembrance
Day.
I mean, it's absolute and total idiocy.
The only other possibility I can think of
and tell me what you think about this.
Trump saying this happened because he doesn't
know what happened to Poland in World War
II is one explanation.
There's a more sinister one though, which
is that Trump knows Germany invaded Poland
in World War II and he likes it.
I don't actually think that that's what's
going on here.
I don't, I try not to attribute to malice
what can be more than adequately explained
by stupidity and ignorance.
And in this case, uh, Trump has shown and
demonstrated over the last many years, no
knowledge of history whatsoever.
And so I would attribute this to ignorance
and not malice.
We're only a few days from the nine 11 anniversary.
Uh, what is Donald Trump liable to say then?
Not Good.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David.
Dot.
Pacman and while you are there, follow the
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
We will take a quick break, hour long form
deep dive into the writing,
utilization of social media is coming up next.
Really, really important topic and then much
more coming up after that.